STEPHAN LINZNER: Hi.
My name Stephan Linzner.
And I'm a developer of
[INAUDIBLE] on the Android
team here at Google.
Today, I'm going to talk about
a new testing API which we've
introduced with Android
4.3, UiAutomation.
UiAutomation is a new API that
introduces full screen
introspection support
into the Android
instrumentation framework.
Why is this important?
Because it enables testing
across application boundaries
within your instrumentation
tests.
But let's have a look
at a quick example.
Here are some screenshots of
the new Google Maps App.
Let's say we want to write a
functional test for this
scenario using the
instrumentation framework.
What we would do is to start
activity on the left.
Click on the Navigation icon.
Wait for the dialog to appear.
Then click the Enable button.
But, as of now, there
was no easy way to
actually turn a GPS on.
The problem is that the
instrumentation framework is
limited to test within its
target package only.
With UiAutomation, this
restriction no longer holds.
And now we can test the
complete user flow.
Go to the Settings screen,
enable the GPS by checking the
box, and press the
Back button.
So let's have a quick look
at the API supported by
UiAutomation.
UiAutomation enables full screen
introspection support
using the accessibility
attributes.
It allows for taking screenshots
from right within
your instrumentation tests.
And I know this was a feature
that was requested
for a very long time.
It also supports the change of
the device orientation and
injection of raw input events.
Maybe one more note here.
UiAutomation is a very low level
API, but this was done
on purpose to encourage
development of your iTesting
tools such as UiAutomator, as
well as to allow developers to
use it in their instrumentation
tests.
And in fact, the UiAutomator
framework, which we introduced
with Jelly Bean 4.1, is
built on top of the
UiAutomation APIs.
So let's have a look
at some code.
What do you have to do to get
started with your automation?
It's very simple.
You just have to inherit from
instrumentation test case or
from any other subcloud
like activity
instrumentation test case two.
Then, in your test method just
call getInstrumentati
on.getUiAutomation to get
a reference to the
UiAutomation object.
The question is, how do
you run these tests?
It's not so different from
what it was before.
You just have to use the adb
shell am Instrument command,
with providing the minus w
option, your target package,
and your test runner.
So let me show you how you could
introspect any visible
screen content from within your
instrumentation tests.
First, we get a reference to the
UiAutomation object, but
as the window content is
presented as a tree of
accessibility notes, in this
case, we have to obtain the
active window route
accessibility note first.
This is done by calling, get
root in activity window.
From there, we can continue
and create for any note by
text or ID.
But note, this search is
always relative to the
retrieved root accessibility
note.
Another cool feature, which
UiAutomation introduces, is to
capture screenshots using the
instrumentation framework.
In order to retrieve a bitmap of
the current screen content,
we have to call take screenshot,
which returns a
bitmap object, which then can be
written to the file system.
UiAutomation also allows for
the injection of raw
ImputEvents into the system.
In order to inject an Event,
you have to call the
injectInputEvent method.
For example, if you want to
inject a MotionEvent, just
obtain an Event object
from the pool and
pass it as a parameter.
But note that it's your
responsibility to recycle the
ImputEvent and return
it to the pool.
Furthermore, you can execute
commands and listen for their
corresponding accessibility
events using an
AccessibilityEvent filter.
For example, we can pass a
runnable as a parameter to
execute and wait for event,
which taps on the screen, and
then verify this tap
by listening for a
CorrespondingAcc
essibilityEvent.
But what you also can
do is listen for all
AccessibilityEvents in
the EventStream.
This is also very easy by just
passing an instance of
UnaccessibilityEventListener
to the set on
AccessibilityEventListener
method.
You're listener interface then
receives a call back each time
an accessibility event occurs.
Thank you very much
for listening.
And happy testing.